evènement dit bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
vous affirmez avoir assister au
tabassage d'un homme par des policiers
qu'est ce qui s'est passé très
concrètement ce jour là vous nous
raconter très concrètement
moi j'étais en garde à vue pour aide aux
exilés j'ai filmé la police qui évacue
et une personnes exilées qui dormait sur
un carton j'ai passé à 40 heures en
garde à vue et pendant cette garde à vue
au bout de 38 heures une personne qui
était en garde à vue avec moi depuis un
certain temps tapait sur les fenêtres
faisait du bruit
le chef de poste s'est interposé pour
lui dire d'arrêter il a continué le chef
de poste lui a dit tu vas fermer ta
gueule sinon ça va mal finir et quelques
minutes après il est revenu avec des
collègues ils ont sorti de sa cellule
et là il s'est passé une chose
incroyable c'est que je crois qu'ils lui
ont fait une prise d'étranglement il
sait il est tombé en syncope et derrière
les policiers qui étaient présents avec
ce chef de poste se sont inquiétés du
fait qu'ils ne se réveiller pas donc là
s'en est suivie une distribution de
claques importante assez forte de façon
à ce que ces personnes se réveillent
l'agent chef de poste a dit ne
t'inquiète pas à ses collègues il va se
réveiller j'ai appris ça à l'école et ça
va bien se passer
après cette distribution de claques
cette personne s'est réveillée très
agité et derrière les coups se sont mis
à pleuvoir avec cette personne qui était
dans le couloir et qui n'était pas dans
sa cellule et on a entendu cette
personne hurler derrière les détenus et
les gardés à vue ont dit à ses policiers
d'arrêter
et en fait ça a continué et cette
personne à ce qu'elles étaient violentes
au tout début lorsqu'elle tape et donc
sur les vitres est ce qu elle a eu des
gestes de violence envers les policiers
est ce qu elle était agressive alors
elle était en garde à vue c'est clair
que le co-détenu j'avais des propos pas
très sympa au niveau de la police par
contre il était dans sa cellule en ferme
et donc à taper sur les vitres il était
violent envers personne
donc non il était il était enfermé dans
sa cellule en fait alors le parquet a
donc annoncé avoir ouvert une enquête
qu'est ce que vous en attendez vous
aujourd'hui pas moi ce que j'en attends
c'est que le commissariat du 19ème
utopia travail dans la rue accompagné
des mineurs dans ce comité rien depuis
plus de deux ans et c'est les mineurs
primo arrivants qui sont orientés
directement vers ce commissariat
on a fait plusieurs signalements
concernant ce commissariat sur la prise
en charge de ces enfants qui se fait
vraiment dans des mauvaises positions
avec des propos racistes avec vraiment
quelque chose qui est de la maltraitance
envers des enfants est derrière nous ce
qu'on attend tout simplement c'est que
les agissements de certaines personnes
de ce commissariat de police et je ne
ferai pas de généralités c'est pas tout
le monde est bien puisse être jugé sur
ce qui s'est passé et qu'on puisse nous
témoigner et c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
une main courante de façon à pouvoir
dommage je l'espère avoir accès au
dossier et que l'igpn fasse son travail
de façon à ce qu'on puisse nous entendre
moi et les codétenus de façon à ce qu'on
puisse imaginer que ce qui s'est passé
là dans ce commissariat
c'est tout simplement inadmissible et
que ces policiers qu'ils ont qui sont
dans ce commissariat et qui font ce
genre de choses pour moi et pour pas mal
de compatriotes n'ont rien à faire dans
la police alors on a entendu le
témoignage ces derniers jours d'un
journaliste qui s'est infiltré pendant
deux ans dans la police parisienne
elle lui il évoque dans un livre paru
récemment des tabassages des pratiques
racistes est ce que vous estimez que ce
à quoi vous avez assisté n'est pas un
cas isolé
c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai témoigné
que j'ai voulu porter ma parole c'est
tout simplement parce que va ça tombe en
même temps que ça corroborent ce que ce
écrit dans son bouquin que les pratiques
de ce commissariat je dirais pas que
c'est une généralité au niveau national
mais combien sur dans certains
commissariats et on peut imaginer que ce
n'est pas une poignée de policiers qui
se comporte mal mais qu'il ya un vrai
malaise dans la police qui ne font pas
le traiter en disant non mais ce nul
effet que de quelques-uns et qu'il est
temps de prendre ce problème interne
dans notre police à bras le corps de
façon à pouvoir imaginer que la police
républicaine n'est pas là pour gérer ces
situations de cette façon là et que pour
moi ces gens ne sont pas des policiers
ce sont des voyous merci beaucoup yann
nazis d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous avez porté plainte
au commissariat après avoir assisté à
des tabassages dans un commissariat de
police et celle